- Oh.
- [Kelly] You can tell, yeah.
- [Kate] Can I tell you something?
- What?
- When you sang that
song on 'American Idol'.
- [Kelly] Oh sorry.
(inhales sharply) Yeah I..
- [Kate] I lost it.
- I was pregnant too.
- I lost it with you.
- But it does, but becoming a parent.
(Kate singing sadly)
Exactly.
- [Kelly] You know it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So, no, you know, what's interesting
though that dynamic is I,
everything changed whenever I became a mom
because then I realized
- [Kate] Yes.
- the gravity of the situation.
- [Kate] Right.
- And that's where that song
came from, 'cause I was like,
you know, I accepted a lot of things,
you work through things
- Yeah.
- and then when you become, you're like
how could you leave your, I would never
- leave my kid.
- No, I know.
- It's crazy.
- [Kate] But you know,
then you have to do that
and then you have to get to the point,
then you have to start looking at that,
you know, forgiveness because-
- And their life, and why
they're like they are.
- [Kate] Exactly, exactly,
and talk about repairing.
Like, what does that mean and
is it possible, is it not?
I mean, it's just, you know, we
sometimes it isn't and
- Sometimes it isn't, yeah.
- [Oliver] Sometimes it isn't.
- [Kate] you know, and then sometimes,
it's really important to repair,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- because that's gonna,
it's there, it's available, and it-
- [Kelly] And that's
different for each child.